man I I don't know if you you've had
this before but whenever you have like a
massive serotonin rush like the next day
you're like [ __ ] this is I'm so sad yeah
just I was just sad the next day I was
like [ __ ] even though I was having like
a fun time we were just I was just
hanging out with my friends I was just
like damn I'm just sad I think the
serotonin come down was like really high
yeah I get that uh and that was I was
like oh man this sucks and then the next
day we uh flew to San Francisco uh we
did a sushi stream
where we did uh learned sushi with a
sushi Master yeah Chef right a Michelin
star sushi chef yeah and uh he was very
funny he was great it was a really fun
stream check it out if you haven't uh we
basically just try to prepare Sushi and
Irish not good
I mean we knew you weren't good at
cooking anyway yeah dude she's hard man
I know it looks easy or they're just
kind of like fish there you go dude
that's just hard yeah this man this man
was cutting up cucumbers like it was
like like arts and crafts insane insane
yeah it's almost it's almost like sushi
chef stuff to go through years okay to
get really really good at Sushi yeah
yeah that's crazy man that's crazy dude
this man turn a cucumber into a
Christmas tree
isn't that insane yeah I'm trying to
imagine how yeah yeah I know right
exactly I I didn't know that too until
he showed me did he do it in like the
one fell swim you probably killed him
you probably killed him he was like and
then he did like an accordion with the
Cucumber oh okay yeah and then I tried I
copied exactly what he did and it just
didn't work he just didn't even do
anything and I was like what the [ __ ]
how did he do yeah so I copied him yeah
it's there's there's like some magic
especially like with some of the cutting
techniques I've seen where you just see
like Chef's Lich it's literally
literally like real life sugar which is
like yeah it's what he did that's what
he did I copied that it didn't work so I
realized I'm just not meant to be a chef
but then copied that now I have three
listings
I just have half a cucumber and then
yeah uh I flew back we flew to San
Francisco flew back the same day and the
next day I flew back to Japan and uh
scheduled man yeah it was literally like
one week of just back-to-back stuff and
it was it was pretty fun I mean I got so
much work done it was great I I like it
when I can do a trip like that where I
just go away for a week it's so much
work done come back and done like I I
did the stream as well where I reviewed
cereal with Chris and Ludwig yeah yeah
and that was a lot of fun
um but yeah it was it was just great I
mean getting it's really satisfying
planning out a trip like that and just
getting dude back and then you're like
oh nice all right that was like
productive did you help Chris uh like
practice that Chess at all yeah I'm
wondering like how much he did practice
that chess beforehands I helped him
practice a tiny bit mainly because we
never really ended up just we just
didn't do it um he knew how to play
beforehand though right yeah he knew how
to play he was okay
um I think
yeah he said he was 800 I don't I think
that's cap
um he wouldn't tell me he's writing um I
I think he said he was 800 because
that's like the default rating again I
think so it's like yeah yeah I didn't
play once up to chess.com guys I'm I'm
800.
650 600 maybe
um because he was like I'm gonna do the
Queen's Gambit
he wanted to do the Queen's camber okay
like which is a chess opening uh and
before I was kind of like I was like
well I mean I mean I guess it's fine
like I I told him I was like I would
have just done the classic the E4 yeah
yeah just the [ __ ] moving like it's
easy you're white because he was playing
white as well right so I was like you
could just play that but I was like
honestly you've been playing this entire
time with Queen's Gambit me telling you
to swap it now is not gonna do you any
favors just do it just don't blunder
your queen and he's like and then he
kept saying it he kept saying the days
leading before he's like as long as I
just jump onto the queen I'm happy
that's what he kept saying I kept saying
as long as I don't blunder the queen I
could literally see how tilted he was
after he blundered that quickly yeah
there's a there was a thing that wasn't
picked up on the cameras but after he
did that the round like when the thing
ding went and it was next to boxing he
stood up looked at me and did this
and I was I was like this
yeah yeah it was yeah I mean made a more
dramatic man yeah did a full content
you know I I knew that his opponent was
terrible at chess so I was like honestly
don't worry about it just play yeah how
bad could it go and then it nearly went
extremely badly and then he literally
let his opponent promote to a queen but
apparently he didn't even know that was
a thing
so he was one one move away so in chess
if you move the pawn all the way to the
end of the board you can get a queen
yeah and somehow Chris had thrown his
Queen and then allowed him to get his
Pawn One move away from promoting with
nothing defending it and again I think
they both missed that and they both
missed it yeah and he he was one move
away at any point he could just got
another queen and it probably would have
just ended the game
um he just didn't do it yeah and then
later someone had said that apparently
he just didn't know that was a thing oh
my God so Chris Chris is fighting a man
who is like a pro in boxing and a
toddler in chess so luckily it worked
out for him geez yeah it was like a
really really impressive the event was
insane the event was insane yeah it was
it's like considering how many moving
Parts like I have to like go down for
that kind of event to happen and he was
like talking about it for like ages as
well dude just seeing all the staff
there I was like my God this is so
stressful but he has like a he's like a
team of I think 50 employees so you've
got a really good amount of people
working on the stuff and you know he's
not always there like on the floor be
like you do this it's like it's just
like you know he works with his team and
yeah his team's great yeah and they're
so [ __ ] cool all of them are so nice
yeah just like going to seeing like Live
Events like that going to [ __ ] like Moga
money live and also you know tourism I'm
like [ __ ] live live things a lot of
[ __ ] fun you know yeah yeah that's
why I really want to start doing some as
well and do some more fun life stuff
maybe this year hopefully things first
there's just something about having that
audience energy in front of you that
especially after the pandemic I've just
like sorely sorely missed as well yeah I
think after the tour as well it made me
think like damn I really want to figure
out a way to do some live audience stuff
even if that means me going to America
for like a week to do something well
that's serotonin Rush man it's so good
there's something different man it's
just like it's like you know I love
streaming a lot but I love I love the
idea of having these big things you that
you work towards yeah um and um yeah I'm
really excited I really want to do some
stuff uh keep press build maybe some
stuff coming who knows next year yeah
we'll see we'll see
and it's just great like every time I go
out to LA um you know I think La is a is
an interesting City this is the nicest
way I could say it it's terrible it's a
terrible it's a terrible City but every
time I go there I always get so inspired
seeing how like the Creator scene is
over there how like how hard and crazy
people are working out there
um you know obviously there's some
there's some characters that's that you
know it sucks and a lot of people are
not nice did you ever find out where xqc
was uh no I have no idea okay we just
didn't show up okay I think he I think
he replied actually to Ludwig at like
eight or nine PM being like sorry I just
woke up
I think I think I don't know something
like that so that was that man is on his
own time zone yeah yeah it's what it is
man when you're the biggest you can you
can just not turn up to stuff I guess
yeah no one cares
um uh yeah I I just every time I go
there I get so inspired and like seeing
like seeing Lotto just do his thing man
he's such a super professional and the
stuff that they're doing and pushing
live streaming forward is like oh my God
that's just badass yeah and they're like
how can you see that stuff and not be
like inspired to want to better your own
stuff and push it further yeah it's kind
of like every time I do go to La for
Anime Expo or whatever and like you get
to talk to a lot of these other creators
it does like light a fire on you oh for
sure for sure yeah and then you come
back to Japan you're like like what can
I do here so yeah we can't do anything
yeah which is why I'm like man we should
just make our own we should do it yeah
because like just seeing some of like
the ideas and some of the [ __ ] they can
get away with over there just kind of
like oh I wish I could do this in Japan
as well right yeah yeah because it's
just like the infrastructure is then
it's just a lot
easier just to you know get a be able to
get a camera and just be able to like do
exciting things it's uh you know I have
a lot of problems with um La as as we've
all like mentioned yeah of course uh
we've all had our qualms with it but
it's they they have like all of the
instructor there just to make [ __ ] down
and get [ __ ] yeah I mean like you know
if you want to hire out three guys and
someone who knows how to do a live
broadcast an audio guy who knows how to
get it all done it's like boom you know
like that's easy but in Japan it's like
impossible yeah yeah you know there are
Japanese people who do who do it but
it's like they won't be nearly as
flexible enough
do what we would need them to do and
also they would charge so goddamn much
money where if you know it's it's just
makes more sense at that point just if
you're going to be doing it consistently
just make your own team yeah yeah and
get all this stuff like when we did that
Sushi stream that was three RED cameras
they were using to stream three Cinema
cameras to stream that insane for those
of you don't know each one is like 20
grand no no no there's more more than
that more
like they're like they're like 30 to 40
I think but just just the the camera
yeah and then you need to buy all the
other [ __ ] which adds up a lot it's a
lot yeah the SSD is also red yeah you
can't use others they have their own
proprietary stuff which is kind of a
that's a whole link so patrons we know
what we got for Christmas
I did that uh I did a poker stream
recently as well where I got invited to
play poker with a bunch of Japanese
people who I just only kind of briefly
spoke to once and I kind of thought yeah
this sounds intimidating just turning up
to a it was a shogi building that they
rented out to play poker cool um uh and
it was just they kind of brokenly
messaged me in English being like poker
yes alcohol yes uh and then as I'm like
going over there yeah they mentioned me
being like poker no I'm like what what
do you what but then I get there and
they're like oh yeah all good all good
what the [ __ ] just mention me in
Japanese and I'll Google translate them
I met these people on a stream and one
of them is like a professional poker
player in Japan he travels a lot is that
a thing so so recreational poker is
really big here
um if you want to play you want to pay
in yeah and yeah you can't like win
money necessarily but like yeah a lot of
people like practice here and then they
go to foreign countries to compete
um so a lot of them will go to go across
Europe we'll go across America uh just
playing poker tournaments but they
practice a lot here there's a really big
scene for it here they were telling me
that there was a YouTuber who's in Japan
he's a poke a YouTuber with one million
subscribers and that's a lot I think I
know yeah he has his own brand of poker
chips
yeah that's one million in Japan is
[ __ ] Hook is pretty big in Japan like
you if you look on the map like you go
like Tokyo and type in like poker
there's a lot of Poker places that pop
up right um obviously you can't gamble
any real money it's like all
recreational and you can buy drinks and
stuff and yeah they sometimes they have
like fun tournaments and stuff it's like
it's just for fun and because a lot of
people like playing poker
um and yeah so he was a poker Pro and
they just messaged me being like hey do
you want to come play Poco with us three
and five other people you've never met
who don't speak English and I was like
all right [ __ ] it sure let's do it why
not it went really well they were
already chill they were already fun
um and it made me really want to do like
oh man we should just I was like man I
should just buy a poker table just cut
out some holes for the cards some put
some plexiglass and then hook up cameras
underneath and then have like three
cameras going around I'm like man we
could we could do this it'd be expensive
but I'm wondering like I'm like damn I
should I should I should do this yeah if
you do hit me up because I [ __ ] love
Yeah
do the work do the thing I just want to
play boys
I do I I really want to do some [ __ ]
like that where I'm like all right we
can get a space that is built for like
live stream content where you can like
remake it into some stuff we'll see
we'll see I don't know maybe I'll be
ambitious I don't know I mean poke is
just a lot of fun in general and then
yeah it's easy because it's fun it's
great Hook is the fun part you know have
you ever played poker Cherry yeah I play
poker times I played it in uh Hokkaido
actually like uh earlier this year yeah
when I was up there with a few of my
friends
um yeah like there's a yeah as as Connor
was saying there's a ton of places
especially in like the biggest cities as
well like there's a bunch of portal yeah
in support there's so many
um and super fun and again it's like a
whole buy-in thing and then when you
finish with it you get like kind of I
guess like a credit type of thing
um the way you can use it again to buy
yourself back in right if you go back to
that store for example
um but yeah it's like you just play with
a bunch of like random Japanese people
who are just like having drinks and just
like hanging out it's a good
conversation game yeah it is it's a lot
of time to talk perfect perfect like
boys night just because it's like it's
it's the perfect mix between okay we're
playing a game but also enough time to
just like chill out with the boys and
just have a conversation for sure yeah
anything like that I remember like when
we went to Vegas we tried going to like
the poker tables in Vegas and then yeah
we saw the buy-ins there and we're like
there's like a minimum 100 bucks a hand
yeah and so that's like a minimum right
yeah least a few thousand even sit down
and then I when we walked past it we
just saw like dude people looked intense
yeah and like people were like shouting
and stuff like death situations I think
it's a lot of those people are gambling
with like their entire life like War
yeah uh and so I was like man I don't
think this is the vibe yeah I don't
think this is yeah I think I I wanted to
have a little fun poker game with some
friends maybe but no not not uh so we
just ended up at the roulette table
right